le passé de monsieur le pen ressurgit à
un mauvais moment politique pour lui il
pensait sans doute faire un bon coup
médiatique avec l'heure de vérité ce
soir sur antenne 2 à la veille de son
rassemblement du bourget mais voilà que
l'un de ses plus anciens compagnons
monsieur jean maurice de marquer lui
ressort de bien mauvais souvenirs
le frère d'armes et le frère politique
de jean-marie le pen ne ménage pas ses
coûts dans une interview au monde d'hier
et l'accuse d'avoir une responsabilité
dans la mort de hugues lambert le
milliard de le milliardaire dont hérite
à monsieur le pen d'avoir torturé en
algérie et d'être paranoïaque
rien de moins le patron du front
national déclare c'est un fait les voilà
donc où l'on en est à quelques heures de
cette fameuse heure de vérité
pascal guimier dans cet immeuble de
boulogne billancourt l'imprécateur
jean-maurice de marquer aujourd'hui
porte close
il refuse de parler devant la caméra
après ses graves accusations parues hier
soir dans le monde
jean-maurice de marquer un intime de
jean marie le pen depuis plus de 30 ans
volontaire ensemble pour l'indochine
élus tous les deux pour député
poujadiste en 56 volontaire toujours
ensemble pour l'algérie où ils serviront
comme parachutiste
depuis les deux hommes sont restés des
amis proches membres du front national
de marquer sera même pressenti pour
conduire une liste aux législatives
et puis soudain la rupture de marquez
reprend et amplifie les accusations de
la presse contre le pen le pen
tortionnaires de marquer la firme le pen
a fait partie lui même des équipes qui
torturaient personnellement
personnellement il a mis la main à la
pâte
autre accusation elle touche à
l'héritage lambert une affaire qui
remonte à 1976 à l'époque jean-marie le
pen hérite de plus de 3 milliards de
centimes et d'un hôtel particulier à
saint-cloud problème hubert lambert
éthylique profond mort d'une cirrhose et
est il sain d'esprit lorsqu'il a rédigé
son testament de marquer en doute
plus grave encore il s'interroge sur la
responsabilité de jean marie le pen dans
le décès du même lambert selon de
marquer ne pas l'empêcher de boire ou
l'amener à boire c'était de toute façon
le basculer dans le cercueil
la riposte n'a pas tardé pour jean marie
le pen le vieux camarade de marquer
n'est qu'un allié
notoire un fêlé tout ce qu'il a déclaré
est faux cette rupture fracassante
intervient alors que des remous agite
les rangs du front national plusieurs
fédérations départementales contestent
la constitution des listes pour les
prochaines élections
elle accuse la direction nationale de
leur imposer des candidats dont elles ne
veulent pas donc ce soir à 20h35
quarantaine de monsieur le pen aura sans
doute l'occasion de s'expliquer sur les
accusations portées contre lui par son
ancien compagnon jean maurice de marquer
dans la bataille psychologique qui
s'était engagé au large de mary roa le